[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're here to have we're here to have
the fun times together by the way I am
so in love with you Fortune thank you
for coming back of course thank you
thanks for having me I miss you so much
I haven't seen you since your Christmas
party I didn't see you then I know you
were very busy but when you're hosting a
party you're the you gotta mingle with
everybody can you have parties and
actually in number one enjoy yourself
number two actually talk to the people
there I don't think so I think if you're
hosting it you're kind of screwed you're
basically setting up a situation for
everyone else to have a great time and
you're paying for it
emotionally and financially yeah I think
from that party I self-sabotage so hard
why because two things number one it was
like it was kind of like the first time
I invited people over like yeah in the
like party during the pandemic so I kind
of assumed no one would come and a lot
of people okay this was like like when
we were doing shows yeah like for you
know 2000 seat theaters and you'd show
up and you'd sell 2 000 tickets but only
like 400 people will come yeah because
they'd be like we're just staying home
so I just assumed 100 people RSVP right
10 people will come like my weirdest
most like anti-vaxx friends will all be
sitting around in the back spreading
covid I think it was because that was
the first party people were like I think
we're okay to go to something people
showed up with five six friends yeah
that was weird
and so I it is weird when you're
introducing yourself to people at your
own thing but I feel like it was like
like that party was the first over
correction right after the pandemic and
you know a lot of people I feel like you
have pockets of people all over La that
you're friends with so it was
interesting it was a it was a mix of a
lot it is it was weird like there were a
couple moments where I saw like Sarah
Gilbert see Melissa
Etheridge I get all tongue-tied
um dude come to my window which is a
speech therapist yes just to smoke weed
we should have taken her up on it oh
smoke Melissa Etheridge
we were kicking ourselves highly
recommend that remember that remember
when I had all those different color
hair I do I I you did go through a lot
of hair colors you were just like let's
see yeah don't smoke Melissa etheridge's
weed until you're ready to have purple
hair that's what led to the hair how do
you feel being back here
um kind of like boring but I feel very
uh uh relieved that everyone else
thinks I'm okay okay oh cause they saw
your colored hair the the blues and the
pinks and they're like are are you okay
if a woman who's 40 doesn't have kids
has blue hair everyone assumes they're
like on ketamine okay if a woman who's
40 without kids or a husband is having
fun people assume they're on like
they're like methadone something's up
with Whitney your hair is blue so I my
hair being Brown again it's nice for
people to go hey good to see you instead
of like how's uh they're like she's on
the right medication
oh so you cracked the cocktail up oh so
the conservatorship works thank God your
conservator dyed your hair
it's also like um uh it's nice to not
wake up to 14 texts that just say are
you okay oh really people were checking
on you but yeah having it back is you
know you're back to witness and
everyone's like you look so good and so
young it's almost like God knew what
color works yeah yeah yeah you know
everyone's like you look so much younger
I'm like why didn't anyone tell me that
I look like Courtney loves bloated
corpse I think I think if it was a
pandemic everyone's like wouldn't you
just having a moment
by the way say what you want about my
pandemic meltdown I did not do one Zoom
comedy show there you go y'all are out
there doing comedy soon comedy shows at
noon and you're like but Whitney's crazy
over there dying her hair purple yeah
um I want to go back to oh yeah the
party I was so Rusty on socializing yeah
and I think I still was I think I was
too I don't think I was like remember
the thing where you're like oh you don't
know if you're in a hug well yeah it was
still like weird it was still we were so
trained to believe that like hugging
someone would kill their grandfather I
think I went in for a kiss was that
weird
and no too much and I spent so much time
curating the Christmas playlist oh my
God so here's what I'll say about me I
am I have very few skills I am great at
Christmas music I can see I have like
deep Cuts Like Tori Amos covering Little
Drummer Boy wow okay I have Christmas
music that will blow your mind yeah
right and um
I had a RuPaul Christmas song There You
Go and there were a lot of people from
the lgbtqia community there and
for whatever reason the RuPaul song like
was on a on a loop
for truly 45 minutes and I couldn't find
my phone and everyone's looking around I
was like is she playing this because
we're gay like I felt seen I did feel
the same but after like it was like it
went for a good 45 minutes to the point
of It kind of being a weird like hate
cry like I don't know and I couldn't
find my phone and everyone's like we got
it Whitney
like I was like I swear to God I'm not
just playing RuPaul on repeat like I
have so many toxic male Predator songs
to play just like it's on a loop for
some reason so I spent most of my time
looking through my phone oh my gosh well
we had a nice time and your house is
beautiful gosh I feel like that was a
very good like group yeah it's rare that
comedians get to hang out not in
hallways or for public consumption yeah
I was chatting with all kinds of people
and then watching people make crafts it
was great that's right I am so uh
neurotic about socializing that I I have
to turn it into like an activity a
business so oh uh you saw those
made this for her kid
[Laughter]
everyone sign these you can just sign
the back Christy Daniel can you sign it
if you could just but I I I really am
working on not like giving gifts like in
ways that are unhealthy so I was like oh
what I think I'm gonna do is do this
like homemade ornament table where
people bring their kids because I mean
we're at the point where people have
kids now and you're like you can't just
have a party without factoring in your
friends that are parents right so I was
like oh and I also don't want your kids
messing up my house so let's just give
them something to mess up but you did a
nice combo you were like kids early and
then later not to say they couldn't
still be there but I felt like the kids
kind of left yeah and then were
physically forcibly removed by me yes we
came in the latter part I did like a
whole like ornament making station I
love an excuse to go to Michael's I
crushed Joanne's fabrics and I think
that kids like they need something to do
yeah but also I think adults do too I
I'm anxious just floating so I like
socializing if you like habit Color Me
Mine is where I shine yeah that's your
jam I can socialize well if I'm also
kind of doing something like the the
ghost moment of throwing pottery
okay stop talking about my dermatologist
like that
um whenever I come out of like a laser
appointment I'm like it looks like Demi
Moore just threw my face and the movie
Ghost and I haven't done any laser
situations so I I'm reaching the point
where I need to you always look so
healthy how you've been touring like
crazy chubby cheeks it just hides the
wrinkles a quarter of collagen
I was gonna have these giant full Loops
hey girl I decided to get in on this
beauty thing
just so stupid who wants to hear I would
like you to be it would be even more fun
to watch you eat ice cream cones that's
true if your lips because I couldn't
feel my lips and everything's just
falling down my face
how have you been managing all this
touring and having a special out and why
do I feel like you just had a special
out uh well had sweet and salty came out
why do I feel like I was just recently
jealous of you
sweet and salty was my first hour that
came out January of 2020. I mean people
are still talking about it so that's
maybe because the world shut down and it
felt like Tom Stood Still right but it's
been two and a half years and so this
Good Fortune just came out like uh two
weeks ago you always have such good
titles well you know fortunate I know
but still it's like let me ask you
something what were the runner UPS
number two and three oh we tossed around
uh the one because I a lot of the
special I talk about getting engaged
getting married finding Jax her being
the one uh and so but then that it kind
of felt like a reality like a dating
reality show yeah you're gonna find the
one yeah so but that was kind of the
only that was the only other one we
considered I think that's interesting
titles are hard for me for like three
months I was racking my brain comedians
like we can talk for eight hours
straight but we can't get one little
phrase that sums everything up like as
we're like chronic over complicators and
to distill down to one thing that also I
think that we're so um averse to
something corny or right that like every
title just feels like you know well
you're like the ice cream yeah yeah like
when you two scoops like put so much
time into these you know the material
the touring and filming that you're like
I don't want the title of the message
you know mess it all up and I don't like
a title being I don't like funny titles
yeah you know what I mean like it's kind
of like I like things that are just more
like literal because the last thing you
want is for the first joke someone sees
is to kind of bomb yeah you know what I
mean and then it's like if you make two
jokey a title like that's kind of like
why if she can't even yeah make me laugh
with the title why so I'm just like I'm
not trying to make you laugh at all
right yeah I think Jax was like has that
had this title in mind for something
else and she's like why not for the
special and I was like yeah actually
makes sense I love it I love it it's so
just like warming but it's so simple
I've surprised you thought of it I know
it was like right there all along but
yeah I think you know a lot of the
special is just trying to find the good
and things that went awry and also like
being Lucky in life that like I did find
love and got married and and you know
just a lot of double double entendras
with it like it just means different
things how is I mean the love of your
life is here she is in the corner uh
where she belongs she's in the corner oh
I mean why she's not in the kitchen I'll
never understand
um but how has marriage like changed you
know like how like first year versus
second year versus like because I'm
always fascinated by people like how can
we be good at marriage if we've never
been married right you know and like
we're kind of learning as we go I think
it helped that we had been together for
five years when we got married and we
were living together for four so I feel
like at that point you kind of know what
you're getting right I mean I'm always
shocked when people are like I married
the person and then they completely
changed I'm like well who were you for
five years that does not make any sense
to me yeah so I was pretty confident
that I knew who I was marrying and she
knew who she was marrying so it didn't
really change our relationship other
than you you feel like okay we're really
we're really in this we'll see that that
is the thing that I worry about myself
and let me ask you because when you were
together before you were married was
there a moment you're like I'm even
though we're not married I know I'm
gonna be with this person for the rest
of my life oh yeah so you knew that how
long and you think
prettier well I would I mean I knew that
our relationship was very significant
and very like we were going somewhere
when she moved to LA for me because we
were long distance for a year so I was
like I I do not want this you know I I
would feel horrible if someone uprooted
their whole life left their job left
their friends the got to LA to live with
me and I'm like just kidding like do you
think that would be a dick move your
relationship would be as healthy
sustained exist at all had you lived in
the same city when you met
um I think I I don't know I mean I think
we would have figured it out but I do
think the year uh gave us time to like
work through you know you bring your own
baggage to relationships we work through
I just always worry about like
overdosing on someone too fast like if
I'm in the same city I'll just like that
happens with lesbians for sure they're
like moving in like month three so it
did Force us to like Pace Pace it out
get to know each other really know that
this was you know first of all don't
generalize about groups on my podcast
especially my lessons no lesbians take
things very slow
get to know each other
um but yeah I think it made it a little
deeper maybe because because we had to
you know work work at it and you know
make efforts to get to know each other
you're on your phone or you gotta talk
and get to know each other it's not like
a just a physical thing is it funny to
you at all that we still do this for
phone I know right what would it be hey
girl would it be like I guess it would
be like this or a Bluetooth situation
hey girl we still have this headphone
right like this what's up
but this is just so classic I know
don't you think you also like this this
is a whole thing too or just like like
hey hey girl yeah
do you feel like
um there was a moment where where you
guys had to go like like what was the
war exclusive now moment especially when
you're long distance well we both have
different timelines on this one I feel
like this one might have still been
having some fun
wow
slut shame your own wife no generalizing
and no slut shaming okay
I think it was a couple months in for me
it was a month
um but uh yeah we we were kind of having
those talks of like is this you know
something we're gonna keep doing or we
uh you know how's this gonna work we're
gonna stop being uh slut at any point
I don't ask questions I don't care what
happened seven years ago
um but the what sealed the deal uh she
was visiting and it was a couple months
in and I said I was playing soccer
because I had not grown up yet I'm still
playing soccer on Monday nights and she
came to my game and I said if I score a
goal
um you have to be my girlfriend uh and
if I don't I don't know was there if I
did have you seen her play soccer before
like did you know the stakes of this she
felt like she was okay
she thought I'm good and uh I'm not
gonna delete my Grindr account just yet
and then I made the goal of all goals
they it was a corner kick I was in front
of the goal and it came in the air and I
did like a you would think I was on the
Women's National Soccer Team I went I
jumped up hit it with my head
right into the goal most beautiful goal
I've ever made in my entire life and I
looked at her and pointed I think I said
something like you're mine you got this
good head for the rest of your life you
think I just gave that ball was good and
she just and I started laughing so hard
and she just was kind of like stunned
like that is that just happened most
anger man ass you're mine no I don't
think I said that but it was something
of like you know there was some victory
moment that happened with that was the
goal I pictured the goalie like yeah
diving and missing it got a concussion
wow and that was it that was it that
that sealed the deal we were pretty much
that was when we were girlfriends
stupid I don't know and very gay that is
very I will stereotype myself that was a
very gay moment
it's also just so like
like I I mean Armature in the funniest
way because you were already there yeah
I mean the idea yeah it would have
happened yeah
the foregone conclusion yeah I didn't
force her into a relationship but like
if you had missed it like if I had
missed it it would have been you know I
don't know what like well I guess guess
you gotta wait till the next
she would have gone back to Chicago and
had some more fun
and then um like because to I think this
is where I have so much to learn from
you is like like when something starts
to be committed that's when I actually
get more panicked well because you go
like okay now we're together it's like
the little things that don't bother me
that much all of a sudden I now view
them as permanent instead of ephemeral
so it's like you know like sort of like
if you're an asshole that leaves Pizza
out with no plate for example what kind
of animal would do this yeah just leave
a half eaten piece of pizza like off for
an ants are gonna come and copper like
this is a disgusting thing to do yeah
and if I'm just dating you and you do it
it's like oh this is fine but if we're
like married or engaged it's like right
all of a sudden this is the rest of my
life and this is how you think and if
you do this like what about the baby
carriage right yeah um what's the thing
that goes on the top of the car with the
baby in it oh the babies don't go on top
of the car I don't have kids but I do
know that don't put your baby on top of
the car
the cannon you know where the baby goes
is on top of the car
you know when you have a baby in the
thing and then you put on top of the car
what is the baby sticking on top of the
car the car seat the car the car seat
goes in the back what do you carry a
baby with a basket like a a car none of
us have kids
what do they eat but you know sometimes
you can unclip the car seat and put it
and you put on the top of the car you
put the baby on no I put it on the
ground
baby the seats on top of the car
and then you grab it before you go but
if you're Thoughtless and careless
You're Gonna Leave the I don't want to
marry the type of person that's going to
leave the baby in the bucket on top of
the car and forget to put it in the back
seat I think well hopefully no one's
leaving babies on top of the car and by
the way I and and that is why I'm not
having kids
I don't want someone else that knows
nothing about parenting to come into my
life that's right I love how good I am
at it I think with those things you have
to decide what you can live with right
because you can't change everybody's
quirks you can get better at it there's
certainly things that I'm sure Drive
Jack's crazy about me like what uh like
I'm a little bit of a like a beast a
little messy like I leave things around
should it's like why are you putting
this in the sink just go ahead and put
it in the dishwasher like that kind of
stuff or uh and she's and she's a
germaphobe like she washes her hands all
day every day like wash your hands more
like be more can I ask you a question
about that because I do think sometimes
comedians we we accuse people of things
and then it's like I'm like oh you're
being such a germapho why are you like
washing your like hands after you pee
and they're like no no I'm not a
germaphobe you're just a pig she does
she's like you're disgusting yeah she
washes her hands takes showers every
other day
this is normal but like it's not normal
to do meet and greets where you're
straddling your fans for four and a half
hours well exactly it's like after that
she's like okay wash your hands you've
just you know shook like 50 strangers
hands and I go oh yeah you know I don't
think about it because also a comedians
kind of like had a little bit of
Arrested Development for a while we kind
of you know speak for yourself for like
performing at bars for years so I had to
I had to grow up a little bit at home as
far as like being more aware of
things that's a really important one
because I think it's like comedians like
I think of comedians as being like sort
of um uh so self-aware and so sort of
hyper critical like we've thought of
everything yeah we're the first to call
it out in someone else but not ourselves
but all of our adaptive behaviors like
just make no sense to anyone else
because no one has had to adapt to the
Carney life we have right right so it's
like for I had this whole system where
because you know we're on the road so
much I just don't really unpack I just
yeah same I'll just keep everything in
the luggage right by the door and I'll
take out the wash it but I leave
everything like I and it just looks like
I'm being messy and slow I just start
putting in my office now yeah so it's
kind of like oh I love you enough to
change this thing about myself yeah
instead of leaving in the middle of the
den I'll know the comedian never would
have thought that was weird right yeah
for sure so it's just sort of being more
mindful of the other person uh what
about you're engaging with your fans and
stuff like is there ever any like like
you know I I try to like be sensitive if
I'm with someone about how I comport
myself with fans because I feel like we
have such a close connection with our
family well I have seen you and your
fans they'd be like grabbing your boobs
and signing your boobs and kissing you
on the lips
yeah we're all jealous oh my if you
would wash your hands more I'd let you
grab my boobs I was like I'm not quite
doing that with my fans so you get very
up close and personal with food that's
evolved in a way you touch me tour it
literally was people touching you after
shows yeah Jack's heart palpitations
because of her germ issues I mean but
also like that's where we're gonna draw
the line I think for me like that's like
an immersion therapy you mean grabbing
my boobs is that's the line by the way I
am a female comic this is the least
violated I've ever felt at least you
guys paid money to do it that's true and
come here like at least there's a camera
documenting it yes we're jealous yeah
like for me it's like I just don't
um uh I just I think I'm finally at a
point in what I do where I I'm not like
scared of my own and I hate saying fans
because like that's as if they're ours
and no one else's like I think they love
all of us and you know comedy fans in
general but I think that like for
longest time maybe just because being a
a straight girl that started you know
you just it's a lot of sex stuff it just
is you know it is what it is and I think
that um in the beginning I maybe got
some fans that like scared me a little
bit and I used to have to be like and
then I feel grateful that as I like
evolved as a person as a comedian it was
felt less the need to neuter myself and
like be a God Like bro that talks about
pussies and stuff I started getting the
kind of fans that I like like to me the
the the the the true like heroine of
like doing what we do is like making
people laugh and then seeing them
afterwards and like oh my God I wasn't
wrong right it was right to come to
Omaha and like give up everything and
like sacrifice my health and my personal
to make you laugh like I'm like I'm so
glad you're the person I work for and
like you know I think that and after the
pandemic it was just like I was so
grateful also that people were showing
up at all and taking such big risks that
it was just like it kind of evolved into
like this immersion therapy of like
we've been so afraid of germs for so
long and I just want to like overcome
that fear and now it's turned into like
these
really tricky orgies
girl I watch those videos I'm enjoying
your meet and greets and
um I mean I think my the the people that
have come to my shows they're usually
bringing me like cupcakes you know it's
very like sweet this podcast is brought
to you by better hell better help is a
miracle
um if I have learned anything uh it is
that you and everyone needs to basically
talk to people that are not permanently
entrenched in your life about your
problems because sometimes for me like
talking to a therapist is a miracle
because sometimes I think I have a lot
of big problems I have to solve but the
problem I have is I just kind of need to
be heard and say it out loud to somebody
and then I'm like oh I feel better like
I thought I had to like send that email
like you know stating that I don't
appreciate you talking to me it's like
no I kind of just need to like get over
that you know I kind of just need to
like have breakfast before work I can't
you know what I mean like I love therapy
because it makes me sounds crazy how
much fewer problems I have than I think
I have you know
um I know that's a weird thing to say
but it's like it's I don't know it's a
game changer for me I think the hardest
thing about therapy for me was like I
don't have time that was the main
narrative like I don't have time I don't
have time but I realize if you just go
to therapy once a week especially with
better help you can just do it um I was
gonna say digitally what a dork on the
etherweb technically correct so cyber
how do you what was called like I go to
therapy digitally what would you say
remotely yeah but that's a little online
yeah especially you have no excuse
anymore back in my day we had to drive
down to the therapists and park at the
meter and get a quarter this is actually
all true so now there's no excuse to not
heal your own wounds get your life
together talk to someone it will save
you time I go to therapy every week
because it Frees up my time because if I
don't go to therapy then I end up saying
yes to a bunch of things I don't want to
say yes to people pleasing
micromartering managing rescuing
procrastination leading to perfectionism
leading to paralysis you just you get it
is the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to watch nope match
is by the way that's an amazing business
I can pay to watch a therapist
in a session the only thing to me better
than being in therapy is being able to
be like like a ring camera on the wall
watching people in therapy oh my God I'm
calling Shark Tank the therapy Channel
yeah totally oh my God being able to
live stream people's therapy I do this
live stream of bears and um Yellowstone
and polar bears that would be Heaven
okay we'll patent that in a minute fill
out a brief questionnaire and imagine
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it could not be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
Whitney that's better help
help
I just do they spell out the word help
for all the podcast hosts or just me I
feel like this was Bert kreischer's copy
why am I the one that they're like
h-e-l-b
betterhelp.com Whitney Okay so
I'm a sexy gal I joke a lot about how
men don't find me attractive because you
know they're intimidated by me or I
emasculate them or I have an ugly voice
the truth is I'm hot as shit okay and
only getting hotter and I believe this
to be true I know this sounds crazy but
just hear me out like remember the good
old days when you were like oh when I'm
40 I'll be out to pasture and no one
would want to have sex in me it's like
the opposite MILF porn number one okay
that's the sole reason I don't want to
become a mom at this point I'll just get
more fuckable I thought people were
gonna lose their sex appeal I don't know
what's going on I've been dating younger
guys they think I'm hot I can't explain
it but there's a lot of
Pro it's you gotta last it's like you
know I'm gonna be honest with you for a
woman to have an orgasm I know this is a
fairly recent phenomenon you you have to
go on for a long time okay so you have
to be able to like pull it together and
not release until I'm good and ready
okay it takes me like 45 minutes just to
do the physical part alone and then I
have to Google myself and then you have
to read me a chapter of my book and then
I can come Roman swipes do not leave
home without them Roman swipes are
convenient over-the-counter wipes that
are clinically proven to help you last
longer in bed they're uniquely
formulated to reduce overstimulation
without eliminating sensation altogether
in a 2019 study they were proven to
increase time to orgasm by more than
four percent or X
4X x
to use just remove the Disposable wipe
from its discrete pocket size pack wipe
on the most sensitive parts of your
penil cavity and then allow it to dry
for about five minutes and when used as
directed Roman swipes have no scent or
taste so there's just no transfer to
your partner they're safe effective and
no prescription is needed all swipe
orders include free two-day shipping and
arrive and unmarked packaging try today
for as little as 275 per swipe look at
me I'm swiping my thumb I haven't used
the Roman swipes myself I have
benefited from them but this is crazy
how fast it works can I put this on my
heart
try swipes today with a special offer
just for our listeners get 20 off your
first order just go to ro.co good today
that's r o dot c o slash good for twenty
percent off I can't feel my thumb I feel
very um uh what's the word like it's
helped me just being in therapy and
being doing Equine Therapy and stuff I'm
able to really set boundaries with my
energy like no one touches me that I
don't want to touch me right I have the
mic in my hand and I don't let anyone
touch other people that can't like it's
very very controlled environment the
meet and greets like but I'll post it
when it looks chaotic and crazy and then
everyone's like oh that's what it's
always like so when people are like can
you sign my tits or time ago nope that
was a one-time thing I see not feeling
it tonight like that's not the energy so
you decide when you yeah but it's like
it's it's like the um I would love to
hear your I put my marker away
save that for another time when you're
feeling it but I do think there's like
it's it's who am I to judge what other
people think is fun like when girls you
know feel like you know like why can't
women be the same role of what the rock
star used to be like why can't a female
Comics sign if if it's if someone wants
it and thinks it's fun and funny and
wants that I don't know who am I to say
like this is inappropriate I'm not
coming right you know what I mean like
who am I if you this is funny and you
want me to do this and I feel
comfortable and no one's getting hurt
like if you're good with it I just don't
think people would just think to ask me
to sign their boobs you know I don't put
that energy out I guess because I'm
talking about like silly things so I
guess that just doesn't yeah really
cross their minds
crowd work videos like yeah I feel
that's a big thing right now yeah but
people say to me like oh the signing
doesn't that get out of control I'm like
don't you get annoyed after posting all
these crowd work videos that people come
to shows before that or they like I feel
like there's a little bit of a I don't
know if you've noticed like at your
shows at all I feel like people are like
in the front they're like we're going to
get this crowd Work video I know a lot
of people that post those that now
people come trying to participate in the
show oh interesting I heard that I
haven't posted crowd work videos before
so I don't I don't I haven't experienced
it yet but uh someone told me that that
has become more of a thing at clubs now
that people are yelling things out or
trying to be fun me trying to be part of
the show because they think they're
helping yeah
yeah for your social yeah yeah I was a
store last night yeah I was trying to
like
I was asking questions to the crowd I
wasn't filming it just as part of our
normal routine sort of can you know I
just feel like in that in the or it's
yeah you need to connect a little bit
before you get into your material yes
and then uh this is like a room at the
comedy store that's the energy is like
if you're at all fake or desperate or
rushing they'll Eat You Alive yeah so
you got to get up there and just like
get them on your side before you really
go into material if if you're just like
doing straight up material right off the
bat they're like okay yeah uh so yeah
this guy was like trying to yell out
jokes though and I was like oh don't
leave that part to me you know but I
don't know if maybe in his head it was
part of that but I wasn't like I said I
wasn't filming it that's such a bummer
is that like a tick tock thing what is
that what where did that become a thing
I think that Comics like you know I'm
generalizing but like I think a lot of
comics is like you know we feel this
need to constantly be providing an
endless stream of content to like fans
or future fans but we don't want to burn
our
keep posting clips of a special people
already watched then you're like
punishing your fans so it's like people
are trying to post stand up without
burning their stand ups I mean that's
the thing yeah because you know the
material material these days we're all
building towards an hour and so if you
burn it online it really you're like
well shoot what now and unless you're
like some prolific joke writer you know
it's hard to come up with that material
over and over and over again so yeah I I
definitely would be too nervous to burn
that material online so I guess that
does leave like let's see what
spontaneous thing happens on on stage
where did you shoot Good Fortune uh in
Chicago at the Chicago Shakespeare
Theater amazing really cool theater wait
a second I've shot at a Shakespeare
Theater before not
um do you know which one the one in DC
yeah Sydney Harmon Hall it's cool it's
like kind of cruising around incredible
yeah because they they made this like a
state-of-the-art theater on Navy Pier
how did you decide that I don't know I I
think we were like trying to figure out
like I knew I I knew I wanted to Chicago
because that's where I met Jags and I
had filmed sweet and salty in North
Carolina because it was a lot about
growing up and a lot of that happened
there so this was a lot about getting
married engaged and all that stuff this
theater was so cool it was like really
just it was in the round and uh just
like such a cool place do you like I've
known you for like so long I feel like
but I'm now like isn't it weird when
you've known something so long and then
you like you it's just like the coolest
thing which I was like do you know
Fortune themes are and I'm like no I'm
gonna go see her you know I've known you
since like 2007. so weird maybe maybe
yeah literally maybe longer but like
um but to hear like I'm catching Fortune
like just these like giant venues and
like you're just this like massively
like hugely established like comedian
and draw and like and I'm just curious
like as a friend and as a fan like like
we kind I went from like can we make
money right right like is this even a
job like like I don't know if we'll make
this we're kind of stumbling like is
there every moment where you have like
regrouped and been like okay
I've like made it like I'm I this is up
to me now like I'm driving this bus a
little bit and now I need to like make I
feel like I've been like okay I need to
stop operating out of fear and scarcity
and go like now I just need to start
making more like mature like choices
about what I talk about oh yeah and I
really want to be more like careful
about what I put out there whatever like
have you ever had any conscious like
like business Fortune theme store
business brain things where you're like
now that this is a business I never
thought it actually would turn into a
business now that it is like for me I'm
like I just try to not make for example
topical references in my specials okay
you know what I mean it gets old fast
now just because it's like yeah I just
wanted to be able to age well right
right you know like 10 years ago I would
have been like whatever I can get a
laugh on whatever you know Lindsay Lohan
that's probably you evolving as a person
too though right but it's weird to like
look at you and be like she's like this
Empire now oh baby I'm a new tire it's
just weird it's like are used like at
all like I'm trying to catch up to you
you've been a business lady for a while
when I started this story you had it all
it felt like you had it all figured out
yeah bro that's really bad I'm pretty
sure that's my reputation
well once you get rid of that hair that
blue hair
oh like you get so many opportunities
like you know so many people want to
work with you are you kind of ever
consciously like okay I know I can do
movies I know I could develop a TV show
I know I could do this with you know
your podcast or another podcast but like
for now I'm just gonna focus on touring
in the special then I'll focus on like
what's your
um yeah I think uh right now it's kind
of like that because I just filmed this
thing for five months in Toronto so I
kind of know like well there's a
possibility being like like oh yeah a TV
show with Arnold Schwarzenegger it was
like this that's wild uh yeah it was
crazy it's super fun it was like this uh
did you meet the mini horses in his
house I did I met the mini horse whiskey
whiskey Lulu
um this is this is the different careers
that the path that we have well I did
not see this one coming I didn't know
you are starring in a TV show with
Arnold Schwarzenegger well he's a star I
was called to write the movie about his
mini horses oh really
amazing
I hope you wrote it
they literally called me like we have
the project for you I'm like involves
Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm listening it's
about his mini horses are you like cool
Google
nice that could be a big hit girl
um so I it was this crazy action Series
so fun uh the hope is that there will be
another season but so we have to kind of
plan a tour with the possibility that
that could happen so right now I'm
focused on just stand up yeah uh but for
me I'm also he was the governor yeah
I know it's a wild
does everyone just knows that yeah
everyone knows I think everyone knows
okay
I know everyone technically knows that
happen he still like has like every time
you think about it doesn't it kind of
sound like you're hearing it for the
first time he was governor for like
wasn't like seven or eight years I don't
know how long you can be Governor dude
Arnold Schwarzenegger was the governor
you still like you you guys are just
like that settled in yeah
yeah you're like like you're that's
still not a little like I feel like we
haven't discussed that enough I feel
like we haven't like processed it
actually but he still kind of operates
his life in that way he has like a chief
of staff and uh yeah we we did like a
charity event with him and he sends like
an official letterhead this is pretty
cool someone like that though when you
hang out with them like you've been
around so many like incredible like like
people like once in a lifetime one in a
million type people like was there
something just about his demeanor that
you're like oh I get why you're you oh
100 he he's he's one of the most
Charming people I've ever met and he has
that thing yeah he just has that thing
and he's very kind to people he's he's
still shaking hands kissing babies like
he's that got anything baby and great
baby that was on the top of the car
don't put the baby on top of the car but
no he still has that thing of like he
knows who he is yeah and he he goes
around and he you know it's not ego
thing like oh this person probably wants
to meet me but he's done this for a long
enough time he knows people want to meet
him yeah so he goes around and shakes
hands and is kind and connects with
people like it's very impressive to
watch how he runs his life like and then
like in terms of like working with him
and acting with him like oh is he so
good because I find that sometimes
people like that and the ones that
you're like oh you could be the one that
coasts the most he does not coach and
you meet someone that's like that big of
a winner and you see them working harder
than anyone and you're like I you
deserve everything you have there is no
accident that he is in the position that
he's in he's yeah I mean he he's very
motivational too he'll like suddenly
have like a very motivational speech
that he'll say to people but it's not in
a weird like it's very genuine you're
just like wow that's that is I will join
this call yes
then so oh yeah I want to fuck you I
like men
how did this happen I was wrong but so
so hopefully we get to do that again but
now I'm I'm writing my whole new hour uh
that's the most you know that's the most
daunting thing so for me it's not like
I'm a business what I want to say as a
business person I'm just I think I
leaned into storytelling with my first I
just think you have one of the most
impressive careers of anyone and if
you're telling me it's by accident I'm
gonna no I mean I just work my ass off
okay yeah I mean there's but there was
no like I mean just make some smart
choices this you know what I mean I just
was like I'm gonna work my ass off and
hope that it leads to good things and
I'm gonna try to be smart about what I
do but you know what I mean but it's not
like I I mean there's a lot of times you
know that was coming I was told no all
the time so it was like where do I pivot
I said I got told no here but how can I
pivot to another I'm gonna ask you a
question like yeah do you look back on
anything that that you really wanted
that you don't know and you now in
hindsight you go like thank God I didn't
get that thing well a huge one was I
tested two summers in a row for Saturday
Night Live uh 2009 and uh 2010 and I
wanted it more than anything
um I grew up watching that show I did
the growlings for seven years I studied
sketch studied improv wrote sketches
constantly and I thought like this is
the end all Bill and it was devastating
not to get it
um it's hard to say now like is that am
I glad that that worked out I like where
my career is so I can only assume that
it worked out for the best who knows if
you know maybe professionally it would
have been great and personally it would
have been really difficult and wouldn't
have met Jax you know a lot of things
would have been very different so you
have to say yeah it worked out for the
best I think that's like one of the
hardest things about like what we do is
like the things we came up really
wanting like I'm not saying that SNL
doesn't like I love SNL like I'm a fan
but I think that like it's like it's
like coming up on like oh all my heroes
did it this way right but now that the
way they did it that establishment is
gone right so all these things that we
like pinned our hopes on all these
things like literally my vision board is
in the other room yeah nothing on my
vision board even exists anymore oh wow
it's like not it's like not The Tonight
Show it's like that doesn't change your
life anymore if you just stand up on it
it's fun it's matters but it's not like
snls all these things we were like I've
been wanting this thing for so long but
now what's the new version of that yeah
the pathway is very different now
because a lot of it self-produced these
days you know who knew coming up that
you know you could become a star on Tick
Tock I mean you know that didn't exist
however many years ago but still might
not I mean I don't know but we're in a
simulation but there are but there are
different ways of getting a career yes
versus this pathway that used to you
know like yeah before for us it was like
get on The Tonight Show sit on the couch
you're good yeah you know our generation
I think was very much like get on SNL
now you have a career
um and so when that didn't happen you go
oh well what's the new dream what's the
new make a sex tape like it's like now
it's on my list I don't know what to
tell a 25 year old who's like I want to
be a famous comedian or I'm like I just
say work hard I say workers really hard
and when you deserve it it'll all happen
yeah and it's like wait you know not
wait your turn but if you want to happen
right away it's probably podcasts maybe
or something getting out of your mom's
house or tiger belly and stuff like that
yeah having people with platforms sort
of re you know reach out and and and
show uh you to Their audience that's
certainly very helpful yeah but yeah for
me the the pathway was always just work
your ass off and and be undeniable yeah
try to try to just be good at what you
do and so I've leaned into this this
storytelling aspect of stand up where
I'm just like I'm just thinking about
things that have happened in my life and
current life and past you know growing
up but as such a brilliant like joke
writer like you could like in this sort
of like especially as like women doing
this when you start you're like I think
when we started there was this like you
gotta like just get as many laughs as
possible as quickly as possible yeah
because you're already on borrowed time
someone's already gonna get up and go to
the bathroom if you're not hilarious you
have to work twice as hard to get half
as far like when did you start getting
the confidence and going like you know
what I can like tell these I can like
build up more I can allow more attention
to build before I think with this one
because sweet and salty uh I was doing
clubs and then did and then filmed sweet
and salty so I never got to do many
theaters uh even though I was doing a
lot of Storytelling I was doing all of
the stories in the club and you know
clubs require a lot more joke joke they
don't want it to sit in silence but
otherwise you're gonna hear someone be
like who had the margarita yeah like but
once sweet salty came out I I luckily
got to start doing theaters and then so
for a whole year and a half I wasn't
luck just FYI well it was just like so
cool to like finally be in a venue
that's perfect for storytelling and so
then I got to sit in the silence
sometimes and not feel like you know
someone's gonna order chicken wings uh
when I'm getting to you know these this
big part of the story so I think good
clubs are your people are at dinner and
you're in the background right you're at
a restaurant kind of ambushing people
yeah you're just sort of there to
entertain while they enjoy a
cheeseburger and it's always not like I
love doing gloves I'm doing a club tour
like literally right now because I think
that's
you know like I never want to stop doing
clubs
um and uh uh when you're headlining like
the checks come like 20 minutes into
yourself yeah
literally I know we're at this point I
know I always try to tell like like can
we hold the checks just a little bit
it's just like 20 minutes in and then
you just see like people's like phones
lighting up and yeah your seats going
you know then mowing each other
[Laughter]
yeah so I think that this special is a
lot of Storytelling and some longer
Stories the last two stories are both
like eight to ten minutes but a lot but
a lot of people do they start shorter
and they just got bigger yeah they got
bigger and bigger but but they they do
have a beginning middle and end so it is
I do make it so that I'm gonna take if
you stay on this journey with me you're
gonna it's be rewarded what's it like to
end a story I don't think I ever have
feels good I don't even know my I'm just
like all middle but they're set up but
there's something that happens at the
end of my special that everybody writes
me about so it tells me that they watch
or you know a lot of the people that
watch watch the whole thing so I go oh
good they stayed they stayed with that
those two longer stories that's like
part of why I put the robot at the end
of not the special the last one because
the people like hey great special I'm
like you didn't finish yeah because if
you do it'd be like that robot yeah
right like that was so funny I'm like
really what did you like about it like
it's just hilarious yeah so many times
you didn't finish it anytime people
comment on the part at the end I go oh
my God they watched the whole thing it's
amazing because that's what I want I
mean you know you put it out you want
people to I really tried very hard on
this special and my last special to make
the entire thing a narrative I'm going
to take you on a journey it will have a
beginning middle and end and it will all
come full circle and it'll feel like you
read like oh this hour was a little book
it was a book of my life at that time so
that's like I love hearing that because
I feel like what my brain breaks it down
to is like oh like the Strategic nature
of whatever not for that to sound like
mercenary but like is not only do you
want your comedy be like hilarious it
already was that but also to be like
satisfying yeah like that's the word I
like to use like it's like yeah I can be
funny for now like we know we can tell
jokes for an hour but I want this to be
like satisfying and like people go like
oh all that stuff that was set up in the
beginning like paid off in the end in
this fun as a performer right because we
performed this stuff over and over and
over again so for me the challenge is
how can I find that throughout this two
years or however long of touring because
it doesn't come right away I'm writing
jokes stories right now none of it it
has to do with anything this story
doesn't connect to this story that
doesn't can I just ask Jack something
yeah please do in this one you tell
stories about her yeah are they all like
true-ish or true
like do you do I just find that whenever
I'm daising when I'm telling a story
like he'll be like that was true like
six months ago you've turned it into a
story that is totally unrecognizable
yeah of what happened but like that's
fine you know what I mean do you think
is it true do you see it like take on a
life of its own a little bit or you try
to go like just because that's funny I'm
not gonna say because I just want it to
be true right and is there a difference
you know does it matter I was more I
exaggerated some of the comedy the
reason I ask is like being in a
relationship I'm still struggling with
like
like I'm telling the story because I
want to share our love with the world
and our Dynamic with the world but I
also need to rescue
um like being tolerating me like lying a
little bit because I know what I'm doing
and like this is also like an art and a
science and like you know whereas there
that person's like oh that it didn't
happen like that and you have to kind of
be okay with me exaggerating how
annoying you are
but well this one I I put the that that
part kind of on me okay okay I like uh
took myself down a couple notches right
to exaggerate either way yeah because
it's just I'm an Entertainer yeah it's
like it's the same thing it's just gonna
be clear if I do it this way because I
think in my last relationship I was so
worried about insulting him or being
taking any kind of artistic license yeah
because to me it's not about what
actually happened it's about how I felt
yeah so it's like you only date Butch
women it's like I know that's not
technically true but this is how I feel
right you know what I mean and their
feelings aren't facts but like you need
to be okay with the way this this this
is the story about how it made me feel
not yeah the exactly also to get the
payoff that I needed that was true later
on I needed to set up that like here's
where I was a puss uh and so I have to
reveal all these kind of more
embarrassing things about myself like
she's used to dating this kind of person
I'm this kind of person I was a real
Puss in this situation but I need that
to later on tell you how I did stuff up
do you think in a relationship that's as
like healthy as yours
there can be secrets for a good reason
and by Secrets I don't mean I mean maybe
omissions like I'm still struggling with
like
like if I'm dating someone I want so
badly to tell the truth and what's so
badly to give me no secrets like I saw a
guy at Chipotle today who I thought was
hot but I did not sleep in them and I
didn't even talk to him but he was
really really hot but like I love you
and it's like you didn't need to tell me
I overshare
because I don't want to keep a secret
come home and tell that story he's like
okay like or I'll just be like hey just
FYI I was like a little on the fence
about our relationship today like I love
you I just was in my energy
shut up yeah I don't think yeah she's
like I don't want to hear that or like
like if you go to a restaurant and
someone you slept with walks by and you
kind of like make Ike who's that oh
Someone I Used to Know do you have to
say I slept with that person or can you
just let him walk by
Jax what do you think the woman of ill
repute over here who's fucked everyone
in Chicago
what they named deep dish pizza after
Jack's deep dish pizza
uh no I mean I feel like you we've both
pretty much know like that like we've
not really hid that stuff I just mean
like is do you feel like there's a bat
like a healthy balance of like oh
honesty and omissions that you know when
do you think it's like something to me
when it's like okay I want to keep
something relentlessly honest and then I
feel like is this necessary to share or
am I just sharing this to try to get
credit for being honest and I might be
hurting the person I don't even know
I've never even thought about that
before I mean
I don't think uh we have a lot of
Secrets do we
should you tell her now James do we have
secrets
I just was like I can't accept the fact
that this relationship is like I need
you to tell me that work goes into this
oh of course of course and sometimes I
need to put in more work because I do
get very like tunnel vision I'm a
Workhorse I'm obsessed with working I'm
always thinking about you know as a
comedian there's no off hours it's like
okay we gotta think of I gotta think of
jokes now merch now the tour now I gotta
prep this audition they need an answer
on this thing we got to promote the tour
you know it's like making me laugh
because even when I am fighting like
with some or not fighting or uh growth
opportunity yeah of discussing or like
working on our relationship as we're
doing it I'll be like writing you're
responding in the emails or just like
over like that was funny yeah so I was
like like and then the next time like so
when you're working on your relationship
and you're arguing about something I
just system writing jokes the entire
time I'm even working on the
relationship and that I think that's the
real that would be the downside of being
a comedian our brains don't shut off we
never stop thinking about work we never
stop thinking about what we need to do
we're always trying to think about what
do I need to pose you know what what
tour uh poster do we need to make do you
have like and I'm falling behind type of
thing or do you just have a more I owe
this because mine is more like I'm
falling behind I don't have that much
time left you know I'm gonna be like too
old soon which is all bullshit you know
but I'm just curious is it more like I'm
just trying to keep up
to keep my business healthy or as like
I'd say like a checklist I just have all
these things I've got to do because it's
required of this job right now
um so and you and I do want longevity I
do want to be around I hope that you
know my career is not over in five years
you hope that you know you're setting
yourself up for whatever different
versions of your career are you know so
in my mind again it goes back to working
hard so if anything I have to really try
to stop and be like okay we haven't had
a date night we gotta go do something
but you know Jax is all in with the my
career but I'm sure it's a hard thing to
have it be so all-consuming so if any if
anything if there's any Thorn that would
probably be the one it's just try not to
make our entire life about my career
have you ever had an unhealthy thought
oh God you to me yes so hard for some
kind of pathos or like for sure
dysfunction or sick psychology and it's
just like there's some crazier and
crazier and plenty of dysfunction in my
life don't you worry so
I'm so
um angry at this next generation of
people who get to just date guys and
sleep around now that manscape exists
like manscaped is a goddamn Miracle they
make the most incredible products for
men to groom their balls and their
crevices and their taints and their
hemorrhoids and just all those
unspeakable
areas of the body that I'm expected to
put as deep in my throat as possible
and manscaped was not around when I was
in my 20s and if you do not have
manscaped at this point you are an
ingrate manscaped makes the most
incredible products for guys and also
their packaging there is certain
packaging that guys are just not gonna
buy or if you give it to them they're
not going to want to have out at their
work or on their bathroom or whatever
this is like like uh like if conditioner
was a gun
so I mean it's like like they've made it
look so cool and here's lip balm because
here's the thing when your lips are all
dry and and and Cat That's I have to
deal with it you know what I mean I
don't need you know how disgusting it is
you guys like if in cells just try
putting on ChapStick for a month and see
if you're still not getting laid like
when you smile and it like you know like
a croissant of flakes come off like
maybe just get some chapstick you know I
mean no one wants to like make out with
a lizard
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com Whitney every guy has
manscaped on their wish list getting
products he'll actually use this holiday
season this manscaped situation is
Unstoppable the manscaped performance
package 4.0 also did you see me just
bullshit my way through that mistake Pat
yeah you're like you fell off the title
I had to I accidentally got back on it I
was too proud to mess up uh it also
includes the crop preserver and the crop
reviver Game Changer an anti-chafing
ball deodorant every man needs it give
it to your husband your son your
co-worker your brother there is no
relationship too formal to gift the ball
deodorant okay your balls affect
everyone it's like secondhand smoke like
you don't just get to run around
standing up and sitting down doing this
with your jeans
yeah
you know have guys you know what guys
sit down they have to go
and sit that's your ball wasped Wharf
into my Direction so ball deodorant for
them all keep his North Pole feeling and
smelling fresh
that's 20 off with free shipping this
lip balm is incredible it's like minty
but not like overly minty and it's like
honey honey
20 off with free shipping and
manscape.com Whitney get your man a gift
you'll both enjoy the gift of manscaped
his jingle balls will thank you
we can all get a little body conscious
around the holidays but our friends at
Honey Love shapewear have you covered
you deserve to save big this holiday
season so for a limited time only you
can get honey love on sale get 20 off
your entire order with the code good for
you at honeylove.com support our show
and check them out at honeylove.com and
use the code good for you so you guys
know I am obsessed with undergarments
that do not chafe your taint
um uh try to invade your crevices
assault an interlope on the most
delicate parts of your body I do not
like underwire I do not like stuff that
cuts me in weird places this is the
Honey Love bra I'm wearing it right now
like I don't know how to describe it
except like it shows absolute you can't
tell you're wearing a bra but you don't
look like you're not wearing a bra and
it is so comfortable look at this look
at this I don't know how to prove to you
how comfortable this is but I'm snapping
myself with the straps and it doesn't
even her that's how comfortable this is
it's like having you know what it is I
don't know if this is something they
want me to say but you know how like
Hannibal Lecter had a suit of skin
like it feels like you're wearing
someone else's skin
someone you've killed someone you've
killed but that had softer skin than you
so you skin them and put it on you
like is that something honey love would
want me to say I think it's it feels
like it feels like human skin I can't
it's just so comfortable I feel like it
it like paints on your body like um
airbrush paints onto your body and it is
so flattering it's ridiculous and my
like fake tits look real that's how good
this bra is it makes my fake silicone
balloon titties look like real like 70s
porn Naturals treat yourself to the best
shape we're on the market and save 20
off at honeylove.com with the code good
for you use code good for you at
honeylove.com feel and look as sexy as
possible these holidays with honey love
shapewear ladies you deserve it one of
the hardest things I think for for me
has been to be able to like you can get
healthy and be sane and have balance and
still be funny like you don't have to
hurt yourself to be funny you don't have
to depress you don't have to be
emotionally but I'm telling you what I
need to be doing I didn't say I
necessarily succeed at it I mean I do
like I said I do get so wrapped up in
this career stuff I'm not always like
this is our date night yeah we're doing
Wendy's essentially so so even though
I'm telling you you're looking at her a
lot are you multitasking is this your
Dayton or connecting right yes I like
this game but I'm saying I need to do
that but I do but I'm saying that to
because it is true I need to be better
about doing that I'm not saying I am
doing it successfully can I just be
whatever at this point I mean but I bump
on you know like this I'm just gonna say
the immature thought okay and then I'm
gonna say the way I was conditioned so
it's not not my fault not immature
because no one ever told me anything
else which is like challenging these
things of like you know if it's meant to
be it's meant to be if it's the right
person comes along it's just going to be
easy and effortless balancing that with
relationships take work and every day
you have to fight for it and stay in the
arena like I feel like I have all these
conflicting all equally valid
philosophies on how to make relationship
work and maybe like everything the truth
is somewhere in between right without
balance but I think for me I get
petulant about like relationship takes
work like I have a job like yeah or a
relationship takes work but I just work
so hard to not
like present an inauthentic self it
should be authentic I shouldn't be
working or to me if I'm working on a
relationship I might be meddling and
micromanaging and controlling someone
like is this just effortless to you
the relationship yeah no no I mean
Jackson's the first
this is a first serious relationship I
had ever had the one where you kicked a
soccer ball into the yeah to legitimize
it yeah I mean I dated and I had some
relationships but this is like it was
never a long-term thing never a serious
thing so I've been learning as I go for
seven years and you know so I don't have
this unlock trust me uh but for me it's
like you know I I
I I just don't want to get to the point
where I'm like everything's great uh and
then suddenly she's like I'm out of here
because you hadn't paid attention to me
yeah yeah that's my fear you know so
that's why I have to check myself or you
haven't paid attention for five years
and she's happy
right right you ain't gone it's really
fine she might not want me to spend as
much time around so yeah it's it's kind
of I think about that for sure in my
head I'm like okay like you know don't
be so focused on work you gotta get out
of your
your own self you know so what do you
guys do like that's do you have any like
non-work related like Hobbies or I have
a hard time with hobbies and Recreation
oh interesting and I'm working actively
on it we hike we've been hiking that's
non-work sometimes we talk about work
but I have tried to lightly when anyone
married goes on a hike I'm always like
just pull back I know the date line
thing yeah yeah
I have been trying to be more conscious
about like not having every hike be work
talk even if we just don't talk and it's
just like we're just clearing your hand
together yeah I think that's probably
healthier than like let's talk about
work on this hat I I we should have some
like non-work things that's such a great
like I I think that I like not thought
about it that way before because my
brain assumes that if if there's silence
that there's either number one lack of
chemistry room or two things are awkward
or three you're being boring or like I
guess the ultimate intimacy is to be
able to be silent with someone else yeah
which is sweaty and I think we have that
like we don't feel the need to fill up
every minute with conversation well
that's what I remember when Allison Brie
was on and I asked her this is like the
like I know I'm like Nell over here
trying to function in the world
[Laughter]
's way to the picture you trying to
figure out a relationship
I just like I'm just too literal like I
just don't like I
if you and Dave are like in the same
house you know live together and like if
you're just like doing your thing and he
crossed each other in the hallway like
do you say hi like
like I was just like I love that you're
like how do I be but like
how do I function in a relationship like
where does it end like what like how
much like what do you say like that was
so specific but I'm dead like if you
cross each other in the hallway or
you're just like yo what's up you're
like tell me it's a mom like what are
you gonna do oh don't say hi I literally
have never been at this before
um
this is what confuses
I get so afraid of like setting a
precedent that oh no I've got to say hi
every time
and then you're nervous let's say hi Oh
my God
introduce yourself to your neighbors
like you're just like you did trapped so
it's like I said a president with my
boyfriend now I have to behave this way
every day yeah I think you are way too
much and be like hey hey like that was a
one-time thing I think you were well get
used to that level of congeniality you
were way too in your head about it but
that's where like disappointment and
resentment builds because I think that
the lack of the vagueness and lack of
communication I grew up in a lot of like
can you pass the salt yeah no I'm fine I
grew up with a lot of that which was a
lot of building resentment so I don't
like that either I mean yeah nobody
wants that I'm always trying to figure
out how to so it's like to me it's like
cohabitating with someone like the very
basic things of like I'm gonna go make
coffee like
do I but everybody's doing you want want
like oh I'm bad about that but you get
your own coffee because it's not we're
not on a vacation it's not a honeymoon
I'll get my coffee you get your coffee
that's why there's a pot of coffee I'm
not your Barista I don't work for you
like so if I do it once that I'm like
you're like oh I have to do it every day
but then the next day I'm like oh yeah
and then they're like
and you're like now I just work for you
this is crazy and every morning there's
a new rigmarole trying to yeah and then
it turns out I have her coffee like it's
getting cold I just love that if you do
one thing you assume that that sets the
president
forever yeah but then or you have to go
like
like I know that if someone gets me a
coffee I'm like oh good I think that
this is how it goes I think you should
get them A coffee and say don't expect
this every day
but then I'll be the asshole who's like
you know well I think everybody's
different and every you know they talk
about love languages everyone has
different Love Languages mine is I don't
work for you there that is your love
language
but so I kind of know like the things
that Jax is into and the things that she
doesn't care about as much and sometimes
I get those wrong as well my biggest
fear I think is disappointing someone I
know that's gonna sound shocking but I
think for me I always try to just be
um like disappointing up top oh my God
so that there's no because I see so many
people you said earlier who like things
were great and then they changed I like
to go like I am like I'm a solid C plus
yeah and this is how but I won't I won't
if I give you a b at any point lucky
that is just take the win yeah but
that's like not all like and but I'm
never gonna blow it and I'm never really
gonna go yeah I mean I I don't know I
have never like dissected our
interactions with each other at home so
I don't I feel like there are times that
we do say what's up babe and then other
times we just walk by each other uh but
we don't feel the need to have it be a
certain way every day would you ever but
we're also okay with silence we got it
you're good at improving and then
sometimes you need time apart like
she'll go call her friend you know talk
to her friend I'll go in my office and
do things I I like to go on drives I
love to drive and like listen to
podcasts like I do not mind driving it I
think if Joe would know where to go yes
I mean well I don't really drive around
but I would I mean if I if you won't
move out where I live because it's too
far I know right but you just volunteer
to drive I I don't mind driving like if
I'm stuck on a joke or a story if I I
probably could drive around and clear
that that's cool yeah that's really cool
not cost effective probably should be
walking but no there's something about
there's something so meditative about
driving so if she like when we order
food I'll be like I'll go pick it up
because I like that time I just yeah my
head's clear or I listen to a podcast or
think about a joke what podcast do you
listen to
um I mean I like the murder you know
like my favorite murder that's always a
fun one and my friends different Friends
Podcast if they have like a guest on
that's like that I'm friends with or
that I find funny I like to listen to
that yeah do you guys watch stuff
together yeah yeah you've been watching
I'm so curious what entertainers are
entertained by I mean we like the the
all those crazy Housewives shows I mean
I'm not gonna lie I've even been
watching the Kardashians on Hulu
sometimes I just need to they're
entertaining you know uh but we watch
The Watcher on Netflix and I just
watched that yeah it stressed me out in
a way that I kind of enjoy calm me down
and stress me out at the same time yeah
in the perfect way I started watching
what else are we I'm just curious I like
handmade's tale but you have to really
be in the headspace yeah you really do
she's been like the bee had in space
she's been putting it off she's like I'm
not at that space right now it's also is
there a wedge like it between people if
they they haven't seen the same show
you've seen like to me like when I'm
dating someone and they're like I
haven't seen Hamilton I'm like you ha
you just have to watch it in order for
us to connect so if you like I need you
to just well I she'll fall asleep a lot
and I want to keep going during the
handmaids No No like they're in like
Yellowstone or something oh yeah and uh
and I'll just keep watching and then the
next day she's like you've watched like
two more episodes and I'm like cat you
better catch up you know like I like I
don't even know you anymore like I'm a
different person now yeah like after
I've watched a couple episodes of
handmaid's tale I'm in a different yeah
I'm organizing them but I'm running to
the office like you don't know me yeah
but I like to keep watching and she's
like gone I've after like 15 minutes of
it and I ca then what am I supposed to
do is just stop be like all right I
guess we'll pick it up tomorrow night I
well what I will do what's even worse is
that I'll make the person watch it and
I'll be like over their shoulders don't
do that don't do that I made a friend of
mine I had watch the Marilyn Manson
documentary three times in the same day
and then made a friend of mine watch it
same day yeah and I narrow I before
every scene I was like okay so here's
what the scene is like here's what I
missed the first time I need you to pay
attention to this one part because it's
like crazy put down the juice you'll pee
after like I was just I I so badly want
to
I don't think I feel that way about
anything anything
I love that things get you like so uh I
I think I maybe I'm not taking things in
enough because I literally don't feel
that way about anything I mean I think
it's clear that I'm the well-adjusted
one here so I think you should really
get that looked at because it just seems
like you treat television shows as if
they're fake or maybe and I it's
obviously it's like being too passive
though I am I can be I can be a passive
gal sometimes I just like don't you feel
like it's an Entertainer like I find it
hard to watch things because I'm either
like ah I wish I had gotten that or I
auditioned for that or ah I wish I'd
thought of that or um suck at what I do
like how good the breaking bad people
love it I'm like this just makes me want
to quit this I'm just like how is
someone This brilliant like it makes me
angry you know and um the biggest
compliment I can give you is your
specials make me angry
it's brilliant
you know so it I get really excited when
I get to enjoy entertainment I love this
and I think I can kind of do it more
with drama right it's so into it and
it's like out of the thing that you do
so you can like Ozark I just like oh I
love that show watch Mad Men to last
holiday never seen Madman
dude I'm so jealous that you get to
watch it for them okay then we'll have
to put on but like I know myself when
something's ten Seasons I'm like I know
that I'm my whole I'm not gonna show up
for things I'm gonna like I get that
obsessed so we're gonna start watching
it and we're gonna suddenly you're gonna
pop in the background okay so pause stop
saying hi to each other in the hallway
we have to focus here okay wake up Jax
wait where did he come from
it's no it's What About Bob
um it's so good yeah uh but I'm so glad
I waited but like Ozark I was like
canceled like doctor's appointments it
was that was yeah we love that that
series for sure you know so it's like I
just like you know but for me I do maybe
this is just like my idea of intimacy is
just so warped that like I feel far away
from someone if they haven't watched the
same show I have oh interesting I'm like
we don't even know each other yeah
you're a stranger to me like you're a
stranger too yeah you know
um can I ask you one more question about
this I know I have to let you go soon
but in terms of like having a special
come out like I'm so curious like you
know we used to like go on shows and do
this like do you feel stressed about it
going out in the world like in terms of
like promoting it and like stuff like
that yeah I mean for sure you hope that
people will watch it you know you put so
much into it it's your like baby that
you're like sharing with the world uh so
yeah I feel you know like I put it out
but it's not enough to just put it out
you got to go out there and promote it
and just there's so much content now
that's partly why we have to promote it
even more is to just kind of be like hey
I have this thing I'm really proud of
I'd love for you to watch it it's kind
of that you know so it is stressful do
you feel like though like anything do
you feel like as a performer you've
changed besides just the telling stories
since doing podcasts because it's like
our your fans know you so well now and
people have heard you be so
conversational like don't you feel like
there's a little bit of a difference in
the way the fans interact like you know
in good ways and ways that are make me
have to Pivot where it's like
I'm on stage I'm like I have this joke
about whatever and I'm like I was dating
this guy you know he's uh you know I I
was I dated a guy that was a blue man
and I never did jokes about it at the
time which is just literally I'm the
worst business person on the planet and
I dated a like remember the Blue Man
Group oh really like I dated a blue man
oh wow who would like come home with
Bloom yeah like covered in blue right
you know what I mean and at the time I
just I know exactly like he jerked off
all over my studio which is why it looks
like that but like it just was like I
was too I just you know sometimes you
don't think your own life is interesting
because you're oh right yeah but then so
then I was like I'm gonna work on this
bit about dating a blue man and I was
like oh because you know I was dating
this blue man I thought you're dating a
vet right they knew like so much about
it you're like I have to like yeah make
the timeline work for them I can't just
because you know like yeah one of my
favorite things one time I was like in
the back of the ice house and you know
when you're starting out a comedian
everything happened yes yesterday
so yesterday I yeah and then yesterday
so yesterday someone in the bag just
went it was a big day
ah you're like all this stuff happened
totally so it's like sometimes it's like
yeah oh gosh like yeah now these Segways
have to get like longer yeah create the
world for people yeah
um yeah I mean a lot of these things
were uh well I try to stay on kind of a
timeline with this one so it was like uh
we got engaged we got married we are we
got engaged we had to plan the wedding
we got married we you know so it kind of
fell into a natural timeline uh so that
helped yeah yeah yeah yesterday like I'm
not living a lot Whitney the way you are
but I do I do like to throw in some like
old childhood stuff so that part is a
tougher to set up because you have to be
like how does this make sense when I'm
talking about present day how do I flash
back so it's creating those flashback
moments where people where the
transitions are tricky last question I
swear I'm just fat I'm just so
fascinated by you as like a performer
does anyone inspire you that's not a
comedian
like for me like one of my biggest like
obviously all you know my favorite you
know performers is like you know Wanda
Sykes and Roseanne and all these Ellen
DeGeneres all these people inspired me
and Joan Rivers and George Carlin and
Richard Pryor but like I think I didn't
realize how big of an impact like Wendy
Williams had on me oh really you know
yeah or like Kathy Lee Gifford like I
remember like why like I didn't realize
at the time like that was an influence
to me I watched that show Animaniacs
which was like an animated show back
right I'm just fascinated by asking
comedians like
non-comedies I mean this is a comedy
person my biggest thing was was Carol
Burnett I was like obsessed with her
um but I'm trying to think of a non like
if I remember the Snapple lady
she like was like Snapple yeah yeah I
remember like in like the 90s there was
this woman she was just the snappily and
I remember being like she's funny yeah
and like you're like she just said
something right you emulated your whole
career off of her
this is who I aspire to be the Snapple
lady there she is yeah
that's right does she have kind of a
like a Jersey accent or something I just
remember going like she's funnier than
the other people holding Beverages and
commercials right like she's doing
something yeah you know and I just
remember like every time I would drink
something as a kid I'd be like I was
like I'm gonna try to drink this funny I
mean I'm not gonna lie I watched the
Oprah show a lot yeah I did I loved
Oprah so maybe oh but yeah but that in
terms of building tension and telling
stories like maybe it hasn't come out
until yeah but I'm just faster I'm
always wanting to give away cars
I just haven't yet
oh you sing The Last Word of all of your
sentences yeah
and uh
cars coming
sorry it's a Pontiac not a Tesla it's
you
used
no insurance
you'll have to pay taxes
on it
and it has to be smog checked
and uh there's a special spot on top
where the baby goes oh no
people don't put your baby on top of a
car you know what I mean
there were there were no babies hurting
the filming that sometimes a baby's in a
car seat it's put on top of the car
temporarily when the pairing hundred
percent 100 never no coffee yes
and if you want to hear more of this you
can see Whitney and I on tour
I need to call the babies the
babysitters that we had growing up
really were just like yeah somebody
their qualifications were do they live
in the neighborhood right yeah somebody
left you on top of a car at some point
and uh you're stuck with you I'm not
realize why I've lost this fight so much
is that whenever I'm in an argument with
someone I'm dating and I'm like well if
you if you leave the cap off the
toothpaste or don't put the you know
toilet seat down like what's stopping
you from leaving the baby on the top of
the car that is and driving away I will
say this to you right now that is a
terrible argument
so we can nip that one in the bud
is like the most responsible what if you
just leave the baby on the car and die
on the car seat and they're like why did
you even I never would have done that in
the first place much less and by the way
why have you never said hi to me when we
walked by each other in the house
what's there to say is there anything
else to say oh my God too funny it just
drives me nuts over here
we'll talk later like I don't I can't I
can't just check in with you like just
can I walk down the hallway without
having to like having you do you check
in you do you
oh
I can't hey right funny running into you
here didn't expect to see you yeah like
what's up like I don't have time for
like
what are you I you know I'm in the
hallway yeah can you find another place
to go yeah we're gonna say hi to Jax can
you just keep walking and not make it
weird like did you come here because you
knew I was gonna be here like did you
time this oh you should write a book on
relationships what's burning oh yeah
something is
something is burning oh my God is your
house on fire
well you guys
um this has been a fun podcast I think
something in Whitney's house is burning
um
I am on a tour
Fortune
I'm on Twitter you guys you can see me
in comedy clubs in California coming up
and uh my brand new Live Laugh Love Tour
starts the end of January I'm going to
cities all around the country so go to
fortunevenster.com
to check out those dates
uh okay well
well saw me smell fire and abruptly
leave the room
I don't know if I had a stroke or if
there actually was if I don't know what
happened when I left but did you see how
quickly I jumped out of the chair yeah
you know what I brought back I it's
remember hot glue guns yeah when I was a
kid I would put glue in those hot glue
guns and I would like put it on my hands
like I it's like I loved like the weird
heat but I did
um set a couple things on fire with that
and that's what it smelled like and I
just like ran out of the room sorry
y'all that was psychotic uh Fortune um
uh her new special Good Fortune is I did
just smoke a little weed that was a bad
idea in between this whole fire Fiasco
uh Good Fortune now on Netflix I love
you guys see you soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]